hello and welcome to our Monday night
live show good evening everyone welcome
also to all of you in the chat let's get
going
play some five-minute games I haven't
played any blitz in the last couple of
days gains start and see what happens
I am shawshank 87 who the heck is that
Minda Oh curse by Norris okay
doesn't sound very British to me but
we'll see what happens
yeah I haven't played any Blitz which is
kind of remarkable because well I've
been to them been to the German youth
state championships and yeah four teams
and usually you would expect some some
blitz chess to happen down like in the
evenings or something like that but no
absolutely nothing in that in the area
where you could could meet there was
simply no there were no clocks I think
they did that on purpose to avoid that
people would play blitz chess all the
time so I didn't play a single game but
I was doing the doing my jobs they are
preparing the kids for the games so um
what about this game here we have a
trump no we couldn't I couldn't play any
blitz during the rounds they were simply
were no chess clocks they made sure that
this didn't happen so this is a
complicated position here really not
sure yeah the kids after a while they
they started
to use the mobile phones as Sebastian is
suggesting that's true yeah I'm
wondering if this was a good decision
here my five move a little bit unsure
however however what about the d5 pawn
if we do this am I not isolating him a
little bit him how does he keep the d5
pawn now I didn't didn't bring my own
clock I understand yeah
but beforehand I wasn't thinking about
those things and when I when I got there
I was like who there are no chess clocks
okay I'm trying to get the d5 pawn one
get a four of it I cannot take a four
here unfortunately I think I'm I think I
just take this it's a center pawn so
let's grab it yeah I wonder if pawn to
e4 is actually an idea here keeping this
bishop I would yeah I think I'll go for
it yeah they've been some some some good
German some good coaches around most
notably we had grandmasters Phillips
lasa and a woman Slovakian around no I
didn't play any games this was I mean
that was for kids right I was just a guy
preparing our team so it is basically a
competition
every German state sends an eight-player
a team of eight players and while I was
telling that a blunder de-spawn hmm
hmm okay
on the other hand can he actually take
it I mean night here takes a 5 B 6 to be
7 rupee 8 yeah he cannot take it
immediately
I still overlook that
it looks pretty looks a bit grim it
doesn't grab that okay and now I'm
blundering defy Wow
but he still doesn't take it okay
maybe he can go age form okay check I'm
not sure this check is probably not all
that all that grade I'm trying to get
some play here yeah Berlin Verne wonder
German youth state championships they
did a good job
they also crushed my team with a
fantastically high margin 7.5 was 0.5 it
was pretty pretty bad okay I've tried
some some counter-attack him from this
pretty terrible position but yeah it
should not work
really
but it still has to be somewhat careful
okay so this is this has been worse
right
my position has improved slightly my
ideas to play deform after she takes
before County form yet d3 is got to
check unfortunately hi morning
unfortunately this looks somewhat wrong
but anyway after the capture I'm
threatening b3 it has been worse already
no this is still still do somewhat
interesting I had to go outside our out
of that pen I think check Roxy - isn't
there some tactic he I'm hard to believe
there isn't roopd three Roxy - I don't
said I don't think I think he can take
the three this maybe it's a frigging
check here's our water that's really
really really tough okay so let's do
this
and now my good movie unbelievably maybe
maybe pin check that could work
check and he's in a ton of pins I'm
winning Roxy one has a big threat check
check
I have no time check check check check
black for fits on time yeah
I'm losing on time that was bad I should
really one that should have won that
like here it should just be made somehow
Queen deform maybe or something
NAT ten seconds anyway that wasn't the
easiest game for the first one after
that break so let's see I hope the
second one is better I have a pretty
terrible serious I had a pretty terrible
session two weeks ago I probably had got
soaked in checkmate white somehow no I'm
still working on one stuff and II for
repertoires in the works but but it will
take some time so I've got I requested a
new a new game yeah why probably also
blended the Queen net that wouldn't
surprise me at all check check check
check check check
I am yeah it was just playing on time
gain okay so you su can you use of Khan
Younis the next opponent so we probably
have reponse yoni okay
yeah d5 is pretty good f6 yeah
so yeah this is relatively best for
white they're playing with d3 then back
to C to C just developing us is good I
think maybe bring the night over to b6
keep the Queen away and develop yeah
white is probably playing some before
based setup okay where are you going
with this
usually white plays a three in order to
play a later C form not sure about this
approach probably should be too and then
trying to play B 5 SS IDM it seems
likely
anyway castling seemed simply completely
normal
probably should be too now anyway no
doesn't do that I think he wants to go
b5 somehow yeah I'm keeping it simple
him
and now go 85 provoke b5 after B 5 I
have chances to again control over the
c5 square I think yeah maybe you will
take on your 7 nope
yeah but he's quick enough and I've
actually misjudged that so going to take
yeah this is a little bit annoying he's
ready for c5 maybe maybe this Sam if he
takes I take with the night and I got
before and d4 as potential potential
night squares and currently he doesn't
have a clear route to d5 ok night b1
maybe not B 1 C 3 and so on
interesting it doesn't do it okay so
probably get this get this over the defy
and now he goes for that 93 95 mm so
this one
yeah team season has started in Germany
we have played like almost four weeks
ago and we started with the tie for four
from a very comfortable situation that
was a bit dissatisfying
I also played the draw and a completely
from a completely winning position okay
if he plays Knight c3 can I not take on
c4 I think I can take with a knight
right and it's not yep he's preparing
this even more 93-95 mm mm yeah I cannot
really um get to see for myself
I don't see how yeah
once you go to d6 here in case of 95
maybe yes not f1 and so and this is this
kind of thing not f1 93 no immediately
goes there inter that's an interesting
choice I would have taken with the
c-pawn relay but I'm not sure he's got
this rook yeah
the rook the rook left but I'm not not
so I'm not so sure here if I can get
yeah the get this going
they have the F pawn and D pawn then
it's not so terrible
no I'm not checkmated quickly I think
the thing I may be okay here
just take the I mean it doesn't work at
all it'd probably get checked run into
some silly maid or so that the peace
sacrifice just isn't good I think at
least I'm not going to lose on time I
guess that doesn't seem likely but it's
it's also I mean it's tough to do
something ever Kim probably the piece
egg wasn't as terrible as I initially
thought g5 may be coming
check want some wants myself check
notably the apron check yeah the night
is not great and really not what a game
can be happy that he's playing it as
badly as he does otherwise it would have
been over already
check draw offered check check that
banishment check time warning white
forfeits on time
yeah could have won so easily
I mean anyway well pretty pretty bad
okay so try to get get a new game game
started who do we have mario karta
there's all new opponents that's
interesting haven't played him and he
played him at all so we have a modern
defense or maybe just posing to her
pills yeah what do i do against a six
hmm
I think I go in for I am even looked
look at this all that all that
thoroughly yeah I played this on time
I'm simply sick of losing all those
games on time myself
those those one-way street games and so
I really don't think I need to give it
away all that many points by offering
them and draws them kind of sick of that
so what's going on here Jim let's push
hey I can probably take a call 95
I don't have any any matches against
other players planned at the moment as
suggested in the chat it doesn't feel
like I can organize anything like that I
just have too many too many things to do
yeah I was thinking that before as an
idea this is why I played a c3 but I'm
not entirely happy about it I have to
admit it looks a little bit a little bit
awkward I should have played Bishop c4
of course I did I played Bishop C tune
I should have should have played Bishop
c4 of course I don't know the book Zuka
swung d6 against everything Philidor
defends all indian defense um against
everything yeah you know if you
generally speaking are ok with the
position types which are let's say
slightly slightly passive mostly mostly
as strategically focused if you like
those positions i think it's an option
why not
it's a very very simple way of doing
your opening repertoire but this d6
based systems I've thought about this
myself but never really gotten to it I
mean some of those positions are not not
very much my taste by the way what is
what is black doing here am I not just
attacking him with f5 and stuff
soonish looks very dangerous
I do Krong says it's a German book it
said the book by your Kiku law I think
he he had something like that in the
works but I'm not entirely sure
[Music]
yeah 95 looks normal
hmm he's taking ages him
that's worse than me that's crazy
Bishop c6 what is he doing here taking
the pawn while I'm going for mating
attack Oh interesting
I don't know I don't think the old
Indian is that terrible if you know this
stuff I mean he co played this for ages
and ages and ages against people
preparing like in the German Bundesliga
and and tournaments a language challenge
and they didn't get all that much yeah
winning the chest the problem but the
position already looked pretty pretty
pretty bleak okay let's go on for the
next game I mean of course you are going
to be probably slightly worse in the old
Indian with black but it has a it has a
it has a point because very easy to play
yeah by Usher Schweitzer I mean if black
kid knows his stuff you're not going to
get that in what you're trying to do but
I agree I mean it's not a brilliant
opening but it's it's it's it's not a
bad trade or if you say you want to
learn absolutely zilch and want to get a
game going that is slightly worse and
slightly passive then it's so bad I mean
it's a different thing if you play the
benoni or something you need to get
really regain you will start it for
example um mr. Farley do we get this and
do I get a bingo
do they play something else yeah I think
the pills defense not that bad
Westfalia what do we get here mmm I
should have taken one earlier and this
is super solid iam is basically yeah
just developing stuff
[Music]
I'm just playing it like it's a like
it's a dragon or something like that
it's probably a playable approach am I
able to play b5 in such a situation
if I take b5 can I do that
well Queen takes I don't believe that
huh he's going to do it I mean I I don't
I don't really see a huge issue with it
but it looks kind of weird
[Music]
hmm okay yeah it seems playable I did
not see the Simon Williams been trying
old match someone on reddit was kind of
harsh about it but that it was there it
sucked or something I didn't I didn't
watch it Wow why did he allow that
probably he didn't it was probably just
miss click or something that ending
looks very nice how to do this this
first look a 595 would be great
I can also get in b6 okay five it cannot
really prevent a thing transition into
into a pretty bad ending
yeah but 935 is good and a4 is dropping
I didn't see that match yet maybe I'll
watch some of it
I watched the cards in match against
Hussein off always like to watch cards
and in blitz I said it's just
tremendously strong what he does so that
looks like a pretty nice ending
you can almost Premium 495 white resides
yeah is really no fun him I get this to
c5 and and I can maybe have bring the
King over to c7 and slowly grind it down
he started let's go drain you
this is sooner book handsome really
strong GM from Denmark so I am you can
do that suddenly little move all the
wrinkle and rook b8 by drain you yeah so
this is a little bit uncommon how he
played this the setup here a little bit
uncommon when you go route could be
eight you use your name
don't play c6
okay so this is a very strategically
focused position wide oftentimes goes
form C form mmm okay
I'm trying to trade this yeah I think
he's a really good player I've played
countless blitz games against him and so
very young I think you're very very
sound solid well well-educated player if
you want to want to use that it always
looks like he's playing like not logical
moves so M what do I do here yeah I like
to go see you for in such a position
interesting
yeah I wonder here if I take I mean I
will do that maybe to f4 actually if he
goes to B - I've got Queen D to him I
don't really expect him to take by the
way but it's just a very very normal pre
move to make my day v looks like it's a
threat okay yeah I have the better pawn
structure here in general I think this
is a fairly convenient line for white
where you can just play with absolutely
very little risk and Blackston has to be
careful very simple to play and good
nice question if I have an immortal game
no not really
however one game is definitely a
memorable where I played against an
international master and checkmated him
I had the white pieces and he had his
King on g1 after 20-something moves and
i checkmated him it was very nice of him
that he actually allowed the checkmate
you don't see that all that often but
well he didn't play the game well so
it's really a little bit unfair in a way
no not unfair but I mean a really really
great game both people both players
should should play well and this was was
really a bad day for this guy
so um okay if I check on age 6
I don't think everyone who check that
good
I mean I think we nice at Queenie
several I thought is mandatory and then
rook e1 e3 g3 how does he cover that he
cannot move the knight he cannot move
the bishop and rookie three g3 is coming
because he looks fine right looks fine
what does he do here I go rookie 3 G's
room I think it works
I mean he cannot move any of his pieces
it's a problem
I think he's out of options some rook
maybe rook on Dan I was just thinking
like rook before something like that but
G for I've got covered he could move the
Queen but I still have rookie three that
covers the bishop as well may I think
he's out of moves
yeah this is a line that I really
recommend because it's this whole line
for white it's very simple to play and
you have a super sound and healthy
position okay let's have a look I mean I
think this is right yeah he might
sacrifice might sacrifice actually only
three but I still it should still win
out right here maybe not maybe not
actually if I go look
85 he goes whoop d5 yeah rookie 3a takes
them and it continues yeah this is
continuing look III or what is best here
III made him
time warning check how to do this I feel
I should not go into an ending even
though the ending is probably good but
ok let's let's try the ending he can
hardly okay he can avoid it no no white
is definitely better it's not hard to
tell what's better but I'm not entirely
sure how I should play
g5o good move
that's a good move
check check check check
no I have frigging white forfeits I'm
hoping your time come on
really yeah ya know whatever I'm just
very slow yeah being out of out of shape
iam losing this is terrible really gain
started he was so outplayed him anyway
okay and that happens if you play this
it was winning all the way I mean it can
can can can somehow improve of course
for white and win quicker or something
with it was just a total crush anyway so
who's Webb actually said Lawrence web
doesn't care
okay it's time for this old line a.m.
that I've played a million times it's
just I want to play quick moves not lose
on time again I mean I even add more
tournament in that game okay so FC yeah
I can avoid this with one second
increment but there is no pool on the
SSE with an increment so I'm forced to
play this outdated time controller
basically it's what it is
not even feed has it anymore but we
still have to do it on the on the
Internet because people really love to
play on time in crap positions and you
can get rid of that but it seems to be
unpopular
yeah this is Sabine stone variation yeah
I've gotta I have a soft spot somehow
for this but it's not very good line
yeah it's what it is but that's once in
a while I have to do it again
return to your bad habits probably yeah
I'm already in quite decent shape here I
don't know if I want to trade Queens
though doesn't doesn't feel right yeah
yeah I can this this moves can be played
very quickly of course I had one game
against now now a Grand Master Duan book
where we agreed on a draw and I had more
time on the clock than with what I
started the game I was quite funny okay
so let's get some let's get some space
try to undermine white Center him Wow
can chicken and check their check or
looks kind of okay can check again check
here but where am I going at the end I
don't know I don't know where I'm going
I would like to take d5 but it doesn't
work really
hmm now that wasn't good yeah I didn't
play this well hmm I can check here go
to d2 and grab B to win but he can grab
the six check which is going to be
extremely sharp rook e1 probably Mia
cookie one problem
Bioshock Schweitzer said that he learned
today that most banks still work with
COBOL yeah that's no surprise to me I've
worked in a bank for a long time and
mainframe still kicks there but they
have they still have completely ancient
software sometimes it's really not a big
surprise to me I mean I'm actually
surprised and it's like most banks but
certainly lots of yes how on earth see
stopping here chick chick doesn't work
now he's got lots of porn Sam would be
kind of fitting if somehow he will
promote one of his pawns
check so checking
check
kingi 80 chicks on g7 he got he got tons
of checks
he's got a million of checks I don't
believe it yeah I don't see how I win
this I don't see how I win this it's
really really crazy
maybe happy to be far I'm mourning
because I take on d5 it's a tempo Fortin
tempo maybe I'm running into some sort
of meeting net that would also be cool
and for King takes 97k check form check
check check check check
I didn't see this chick draw offered no
he's got no time but at all plus a nose
position white resigns okay so who
somehow it still felt felt trachea yeah
about the COBOL programming that's funny
I remember back in the day when I was at
the bank it's I don't know exactly what
at what point it was but at some point
they had problems with some mainframe
programs and it was really funny they
wrote they basically sent a message to
all of the employees in the IT and
regained parts basically just saying any
is there anybody around who knows COBOL
yeah yeah it it felt a little bit like
either they like in those movies when
they have them when they have when the
pilots of an airplane and they are sick
from from bad food or so and they they
send a message to the peasant to the
passengers and like anybody around is
actually able to fly a plane and it
really felt a lot like that okay so I
have an open Cicilline against
our kannada not quite sure why I played
Knight c3 on the second move but anyway
[Music]
yeah that was funny when they sent out
that letter there was there was a
colleague of mine and then she said I
actually know COBOL but I have
absolutely no desire to to do this the
stuff again so yeah that's from airplane
eeeh anybody around to actually know
know how to fly a plane
yes we must find a passenger who didn't
eat the fish yes exactly
always loved those movies okay so if
I've threatened checkmate it's a good
way to win if you meet him this is Grand
Master Katya
Rothstein by the way I actually did
prepare against him last year we had we
were playing in the same league but at
the end he didn't he didn't show up some
other guy played so what's going on here
he can actually take only five I think I
probably shouldn't play those Bluff
moves against grandmasters they usually
call
what actually was my intention yeah I
don't know anyway don't see what happens
okay let's go H want that's a kind of
silly attack that I always lose against
hmm maybe so I can go away for I mean
when do you play the Dutch with black
it's a nice question but I don't know
probably when I've got black that
deserve a first good step not with white
and this is probably going to be the
last game of the stream anyhow okay so I
probably have to go here
yeah what's going on yeah he's just as a
pawn up but maybe I'm if I take I have
some ideas like taking only six or maybe
Bishop default so Bishop d4 is actually
interesting if I can get this and
threatening Queen to f6 stuff like that
okay he moves the Queen to some
bad-looking spot but let's go back check
he just wants to trade everything kind
of understandable but but but but he's
got this check on d1 unfortunately I can
take take take g6
and take ecigs and everything but he's
got to check on d1 okay mmm if I take
and then take on a6 what's going on
there he's got this check
yeah I can get this pawn your voice
ma'am we can take a four actually
if he takes a four is Bishop takes a six
maybe possible it would be nice if it
was possible no I'm not guessing a
single move that he plays not a single
one
Jim not happy about this but didn't
really see a good alternative he's got
this chick on the way
I don't know
if it takes it I think I will get to get
to the five bond he will probably play
Queen c3 then queen d8 was my idea
intending Bishop h6 check
yeah I'm worse but he still has to
converted check and a five is also
hanging okay so I take it but should be
six what's wrong about that probably
nothing
that's excellent to me there should be
six I'm basically promoting this thing
now I'm just winning here they porn
promotes he played that in a very
beautiful very weird way I don't know
maybe it wasn't super easy to convert
but this was not a way to do it black
resigns no no I have managed to get to
2,400 at the end that's nice
gained a couple of points in that
session even though I lost pretty silly
games due to time mismanagement okay I
hope you enjoyed the show I am back next
week looking forward to it
it was kind of okay I was a bit slow but
yeah thanks a lot and I'll be back next
week bye bye guys
you